[Music]
hello everyone
uh so we'll start uh our discussions
associated with
the jupiter notebook as i had mentioned
in my last
live session uh through this uh
through this pre-recorded video so i'm
assuming that
all of you have already
installed anaconda and
the way that we are going to start is
by assuming that you are an absolute
beginner
so let's first start uh
firing up jupiter notebook and the way
that i prefer to do it
is uh so i'm using windows 10
uh that's my operating system so i just
go to the start button and
well you can already see that
some things related to anaconda are
already available here
okay so what one would
do usually is to go to this anaconda
navigator
uh click on that and then it will take
some time for that
uh graphical user interface to to pop
up and then you would click this and
that to go into it
uh however what i prefer
is uh is to actually use the
anaconda prompt okay so
it it gives me a direct way of going to
a certain drive
and launching the jupiter notebook as
that as my root
okay so if it doesn't make sense what
i'm saying i i'll just demonstrate in a
minute
so what you do is here uh in this
search bar uh you you just write
anaconda prompt
okay so
when this pops up we click on this
and this kind of the command window it
appears and
by default i mean if you are
i mean if you have not done anything too
adventurous with your
with your settings so this kind of thing
the
the basic the default uh
route should come up like this okay we
don't want to be
uh using the the same drive in which our
operating system is installed
uh rather my working drive is a separate
e drive so i'll
uh i'll change to that okay so i've
changed over to my e drive where all my
uh teaching folders are present
so what i'll do is i launch jupyter
notebook
from from this from this root okay so
it's as easy as just writing jupyter
notebook with a space in between and
then pressing enter
when i press enter what it will do is it
will open up
the jupyter notebook interface uh
as a as a separate tab in the browser
okay so the jupyter notebook
if you want to call it like a software
it it
i mean all the all the visualizations
and everything it is
uh it takes place as a tag in your in
your browser of course
and that does not mean that it is
it is like a like an internet based or a
cloud-based thing
it is very much native to your your
local machine your local computer
uh but still the visualizations take
place uh
as if it is uh as if it is a as a
a net file okay but it is not it is very
much local to your system
okay so let's press enter
and hopefully the
yes uh so
we go to the appropriate place uh so
this this will be something specific to
your system
okay so i'm teaching two courses this
semester elasticity and mechanics of
solids of course we are going to
elasticity
all right and i have already set up one
folder there jupiter notebooks
uh so we you know we go into that
and uh one specific folder so what i'll
do is as you can see i have already
uh i've already created some
some files before this
before this recorded video and i will
not open any of those
okay rather i will just since this is
meant for beginners
what i will do is i'll just open up a
new file because that is what
exactly what you will be doing okay so
we go to this new thing
okay click on this and the number of
options here
we want to open this python 3 okay so we
click on this
and a separate tab opens okay so you
think of it
like this that this new tab that has
opened which by default is called the
that's named as the untitled until just
like any other file
so this is a separate tab from this
original tab
okay so this was like my navigation kind
of thing
and this is the actual jupyter notebook
file that we have
opened up and this is where we are going
to do our work
okay so this is meant for beginners
let's try
i mean things start out in a very very
simple fashion
so as i mentioned in passing during one
of my live sessions earlier
we don't actually have to write full
fledged code here okay
so we can just use it almost like a
calculator so
very basic so two plus two let's say
okay now uh if you just press
enter okay so i'm just pressing enter
now
you see it just goes to the next line it
adjusts the whole boss
box and it just goes to a new line it
doesn't show me the result
so let me just backspace and what i need
to
do in order to obtain my result is to uh
do a shift enter
okay so i press the shift and aft
with the shift key pressed i will press
enter
okay so shift i have pressed and then
enter so now
it gives me the output okay so that's
nice
so as you see now this first cell
okay so these boxes this rectangular
this long rectangular boxes that you see
these are like the cells okay these are
called the cells and
this is the input cell okay so as you
can see it is called in
in one okay so this is the designation
for the input cell number one
uh and this is the output cell number
one okay so similarly we can keep on
doing various things in the various
cells
now uh yeah so just just for uh just for
the kick of it
uh let's do something else maybe 4 into
8 just to show okay so
when you get the idea you can do
whatever you want
now you have to note
something that why are we actually using
this jupyter notebook
okay so whatever i am doing here
i might as well have done from a command
prompt
okay what i mean to say is that if you
are somewhat familiar
with the with the the classical way that
programs are run so you would open up an
editor
you write some lines they'll save it as
a file maybe compile that in a
separate thing or maybe use some kind of
interactive development environment and
do those things
but we're not doing that we have picked
up jupyter notebook
not just because it's kind of stylish or
something like that uh
rather because the visual output
as it is presented as a as a browser tab
is very appealing and it will i mean
this sentence
that the visual output is very appealing
it will make much more sense
uh and you will appreciate it more as we
go forward and do symbolic calculations
that's the idea here
okay but apart from that uh that
that appeal of the the nice visual
output
uh another important thing is that this
jupyter notebook and
it allows a very nice way of
uh of putting in comments okay so
uh if you are familiar with any other
programming language you know that using
some special
uh special symbols you can you can mark
out
some some lines of code as commented
lines
uh now what
what we can do here in jupiter notebook
is to write full-fledged descriptions
okay and this makes it particularly
suitable
uh in a teaching kind of environment in
a teaching learning kind of environment
it is also very useful uh
for making uh reports where
the description as well as the working
out of the of your ideas it is
present in an integrated fashion so let
me describe what i'm
what i'm saying so see this is like a
very simple
calculation this is a very simple
calculation but
you see when i'm clicking on this this
description here
is it's a code okay of course it's not
like a full-fledged code but it's some
sort of
some calculation okay in that sense it's
a code
so there is no description here i'm not
saying that i am adding two plus two i'm
not writing this sentence
here also i'm not writing the sentence
that 4 into 8 okay i could
okay so suppose i mean adopting the
the syntax for putting in comments in
python
we can use the hash symbol and putting
in rank that
here we multiply
4 and 8 okay
we could do that okay of course it's
meaningless here but
we could do that but uh it would
as as our as our computations and
calculations become more involved it
will make
make much more sense to write a full
budget description of our ideas
and to do that what we'll do is we'll
use these cells
okay this cell for example this fresh
cell where i have not put anything in
that itself as a as a comment uh
okay or as a some kind of a
sentence full-fledged english sentence
and the way that i can do it
is i can click on this thing
i hope you can see my cursor here so
i click on this and you see there are
number of options here
okay so what i will choose here is the
markdown option
okay so you see that this may this line
itself has changed is no longer
described as an input okay because this
is going to be
now a markdown thing so markdown is
basically you can you can google
markdown
it's a very easy way of of writing
text but with some added benefits okay
and as we go along you'll see the
benefits
we can put nice links and everything uh
in fact the website that i have that i'm
maintaining for our course
the raw files for that i actually write
in markdown and then i convert it to
html
it's much easier that way okay
so so so for example uh next
uh subsequently if i want to
uh if i want to add two numbers okay so
let's say
we i want to add a equal to 2 uh to be
equal to 3
and then i want to store the result in c
as
a plus b so this is a very simple thing
anybody can understand it but
for the purpose of demonstration let me
just uh show it
all right so what i will do here is that
i'll actually write down the comment
okay and you'll see how visually
appealing this is
also so
in the next cell
we want to add
we had want to add
a equal to 2 to
b equal to 3 okay now you see
here i have put this a equal to 2 within
the dollar dollar symbol
so that is this part within the dollar
dollar
so that is basically telling uh
telling it to mark it out as a latex
thing
okay so as a latex input so latex is
basically
uh one of the oldest uh and most
powerful typesetting
environments and all the typeset nodes
that i provide to you as part of the
applied elasticity course
that i do in a full-fledged later
environment okay so
the good thing about this jupiter
notebook is that it allows markdown
input and within markdown it allows us
to put to input the
the latex input also and that makes the
mathematics
uh presentation in a very nice and clean
fashion okay so let's demonstrate okay
so in the in the next cell we want to
add a uh to b
and uh and then store
the result in c
in the variable c okay now see here
i uh already have told you in order to
get the output of a
of a of a cell
i need to press shift enter so similarly
here okay so i
press shift enter and you see whatever i
had
typed in it gets rendered in such a nice
fashion
okay i hope you can see this it's it's a
nice
properly typeset thing okay and if i
want to
go back and edit it i can just click on
here
click again
so i have to double click actually and i
can edit this cell so for example i can
just uh
so so this is a markdown cell
it allows latex input also
all right so let's actually do this in
the next cell we'll
write a equal to 2 b equal to 3
please note that when you discuss or
when you when you write this comment
that a equal to 2 and b equal to 3 that
is just like
just like a comment it doesn't get
stored anywhere
okay it doesn't do any maths actually
the maths the match part actually has to
be done
in a separate cell which is marked as a
fourth cell
okay not as a mal council so if you go
to the previous one you see this is a
markdown cell
here this is a code 7 the previous one
also was a 4 cell the previous one also
was a code cell
so all these are 4 cells so we store a
equal to 2 b equal to 3 and then we
say c is equal to a plus b
now if i press shift enter you see
nothing happened
well nothing happened because we did not
actually display c
so we'll do that
okay now
uh till now we have not done anything to
do with symbols
okay so let's try to do that so for that
what we'll do is we'll have to first
import the symbolic uh package okay the
symbol
uh the symbolic python package so
in python uh the base uh python
uh we do not have the symbol uh nor do
we have the numerical
computations package so we have to
import all of this whenever we need them
so what we can there are number of
different ways of importing packages
so the way that i prefer to do it
and which is also standard advice
is that we import this package
and and you actually have to know the
name of the package okay so the
the the name of the symbolic python
package is simple
okay some people call it as simpy i i
call it a sim pie
okay so uh we could do this import
sempai
but what i will do is uh i'll i put in a
little
extra decoration here uh well it's not a
decoration it has
it has a meaning but for now let's not
get into the the nitty gritties of
all of this okay so why i am writing
this as as same or something
so as same uh so this thing this sim
okay it is it is purely a purely my
choice okay so let's let's do a shift
enter
uh so you see this asterisk it showed up
for some time
uh it meant that it was loading it took
some time to load
so depending on your computer it may
take a little bit more time little bit
less time whatever
now as i was mentioning the same thing
uh it's
completely your choice okay you can
write it as
input simply as same input simplifies sp
input template as rabbit input sempis
tiger whatever
okay doesn't make any difference but of
course there are some idiomatic
practices within the python community
so like this is more or less standard
that we write it like this some people
write as
sp so in autumn 2019 i was using import
senpai as
sp all throughout the course but i think
this is
that's clear okay so sp is actually
i think more standard way of importing
the the scientific python package
okay so we'll reserve it for that if you
ever need it for now
all throughout this course we are going
to import the symbolic python package
as sim all right now
uh so we have imported the the symbolic
python package
and now we want to begin uh our
demonstrations of that because that is
what we are going to use
uh the most uh in the rest of this
elasticity course and you'll see that
that use is going to make our life
a lot lot easier especially when we go
into
the long run algebra associated with 2d
elasticity
okay so first things first we have to
define the variables
x and y okay so
the way we do it is like this so you
have to know the syntax a little bit
okay which is
which is part of the learning okay
so as simple as that uh so we press
shift enter and you see nothing happened
well nothing happened means it's good
okay so it means it it did it yeah it
has done its work
and now we are ready to begin using our
symbols x and y so without
actually defining this kind of thing uh
without what i have done here in line
this input numbers input cell number six
you cannot use okay without that line
you cannot start writing
uh x y or x plus y all those things you
cannot do you have to first define them
and similarly for all other symbols okay
now uh what do we want to do first let's
say
i mean uh one of the easiest things that
we could do is
we can write something like x plus y
square okay let's try to do that
x plus y okay please note that in python
uh you cannot use this uh this
carrot operator okay so let me just show
you
this carrot operator which you are
probably more familiar with
other programming languages uh that is
not going to work here okay so you have
to use this
double asterisk that is this uh the way
that you
use the power okay similarly for express
y cube
also you have to write double astrix
three or fourth point to write double
asterisks foreign etc etc
okay so now if we do this let's press
shift enter let's see what happens
okay very nicely it has printed out x
plus y whole square
but this is not what we wanted okay we
wanted
the the expansion of this okay
uh so what can we do well
there is a way like literally we can use
the
expand command okay so what we can do is
around this x plus y whole square we can
put a bracket and then just write expand
expand but this this empty parenthesis
is very important so let's see if we if
we do this what happens
so it took a moment uh there but it has
successfully expanded it out
okay now you may see that you may say
that this is very trivial example
but let me just demonstrate the power of
this to you
so let me just copy this previous cell
and do this again but now for the fifth
power
which is not so trivial now you see in
almost the same time that
took earlier it has given me the output
okay
let's go a little bit higher okay let's
go for 10
and now you see okay the convenience it
allows us
so in order i mean if you had to do this
by hand
uh that would have taken some time now
let's really push it let's go 100 let's
see what happens
okay so
it has taken a little bit of time not to
calculate it
but to render it okay and you see
initially it had just printed it out in
a single line which you could not see
properly
but now this thing has actually been
printed out properly in this entire
thing and it didn't take that long a
time if you think about it
okay uh so let me see if i can make this
full screen so i
i think uh this looks a little bit
better now
okay you see that this there is no way
you could have done that by hand
unless of course uh you are i mean
record holder in patience
okay so with that out of the way
let's look at some other things we can
do with symbolic python
now uh you know
that whenever we have to do some
calculations
involving pi
like the area of a circle uh
or something like uh an angle in radians
like pi by 3 so
when writing it on a piece of paper we
can simply write pi
the symbol pi and we all understand what
it is
but if you have to uh make the computer
understand as part of your calculations
if you have some experience with
programming languages you know that
you actually have to write down
write it down as the value of pi okay so
maybe i think in matlab it allows you to
write it like like a pi i think it
understands it if i remember correctly
now what about the symbolic version of
it okay suppose
suppose we we want to write it in a
fashion
that would completely mimic
okay whatever we do on a piece of paper
when writing by hand
okay so
m.py okay so
let's do a shift enter and see what what
it gives us
so you see this symbol is printed out
and this
actually is quite meaningful it is
meaningful because
suppose you want to extract the value of
this pie
what you can do is uh you can use this
kind of an operation
so symbolic dot n means uh
it's an instruction to extract the
numerical value
of a symbol okay so
uh what we can do is we can supply to it
this pi m1 okay so
the instruction here is like this that
it's basically
n of pi okay the numerical value of pi
this same is
basically just to just to have a very
explicit
understanding that we are operating
within the symbolic package
or we are using things from the symbolic
package
so same dot pi is the the pi symbol
and sim dot n is basically just asking
it to extract the numerical value out of
it
so if we do a shift enter so you see
it gives us the numerical value correct
to how many decimal places one
two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
up to fourteen decimal places
uh of course you can control how many
digits it it
it displays so let's try to do that
let's say we want to display uh
uh three significant figures not mind
you not decimal places but three
significant figures
so see 3.14 okay
so if you had wanted up to the third
decimal place then you would have to
write
this as 4. okay so you get the idea
now let's go a little bit crazy
and do a hundred let's see if we can do
it
see how quickly it gives us the value
okay
okay so can even go up to higher and
higher i mean it's a non-terminating
decimal right
so it keeps on going just keeps on going
no problem
and how fast it is okay so let's let's
just
uh bring down down our craziness a
little bit
like that okay uh
so that was good fun but now let us get
into the
actual uh useful things we can uh
do with symbolic python so let's say we
want to
solve two linear simultaneous equations
okay
so what we'll do is
uh again i'm going to use
the markdown cell okay so instead of a
code i'll write down the first markdown
description of it
now this time instead of clicking on
here i will
tell you another way in which i can
quickly convert
using my keyboard itself this cell
which by default is a code cell into a
markdown cell
so with this cursor blinking here
i'll just press escape okay i'm just
pressing escape
so you see this thing has now turned
blue
okay and this cursor is not blinking so
i have
like come out of the editing mode and
now i'm in the command kind of mode
and now if i just press the letter
m on my keyboard m for markdown
okay i'm just pressing m no shift
nothing just m
see automatically it has turned into
this markdown cell
okay and now if i press enter i have not
pressed down on my mouse
uh mousepad or anything i'm just
pressing enter
it has become a markdown cell ready for
editing
okay now if i want to convert this back
to
code a code cell again i have to press
escape
it changes to blue and now i press y
see it has changed to code so i pressed
the letter y
y for yellow okay i don't know why they
have chosen the letter y
but uh it's their decision
the people who made it uh so
so this is a shortcut thing uh you can
use okay so when you are in the flow of
doing your calculations writing your
reports and everything these kinds of
small tricks
it helps you uh stay in the flow okay
and not break your flow
anyway so we want to convert this back
to uh markdown
so again uh escape so
m enter all right so
again i'm going to write a little
description uh we now want to
solve our
two linear simultaneous equations
just like in high school and now we can
actually exploit
the power of the leading input here
so
if you're not familiar with latex don't
worry about it it's just a way of
type setting things beautifully uh so
i'll just uh
just write this down this is this is not
actually the point of
this this demonstration but just to
know that this can be done okay all
right this will be uh useful for you
when you want to write uh the report for
your
uh for your term project okay but then
it will be useful these kinds of things
but for now you
just concentrate on the code parts
okay so let's say we have this uh
one of these equations and another
equation let's say we have
x plus one
uh so there was a bit of a power failure
uh which is why i had to restart
everything
and which is why you you can see here
that
the input cell numbers and output cell
numbers have changed because i ran the
entire notebook
that i was creating again and all the
cells ran sequentially
once and so then the numbers have
changed a little bit
okay but uh other than that everything
else remains the same
okay so everything that i had typed
earlier it remains the same
uh so we continue from
what i was discussing
uh so we have this uh thing uh
so i was writing like this and if i
shift enter it displays these two
equations
now as i mentioned earlier so the
previous one was
a markdown cell and i had just
mentioned what i was going to do so we
actually have to do it now
we have to solve this linear
simultaneous equations so how do we go
about doing that
first of all we have to set up the
equations themselves and then we have to
solve them
so uh
symbolic python actually has
a command for that for setting up
equations uh
and what we'll do is we'll call our
first equation is
eq1 so this is the command
sim dot eq where please note that the e
is
in capital okay so
twice x plus price y
comma eight so
whatever comes before the comma within
this
eq command this twice x plus three y
that constitutes the left-hand side and
what comes after the comma that
constitutes
the right-hand side we might as well
write the same equation by writing on
the right hand side
0 and on the left-hand side minus 8
it's absolutely the same thing okay so
we'll just
keep it in the same format that we had
written in this markdown cell here
so this is our equation 1 and equation 2
similarly will be
sim dot eq
twice x plus
y comma y
all right so if we do a shift enter here
as you can expect nothing really happens
because we have only
set up our equations what we can do is
go back to this cell
and display the two equations okay and
this display command it actually takes
it can take more than one input
okay so i just say display eq1 aq2
all right so that looks good but again
uh
so there is you please note that there
is a difference between the way that
this is displayed here and it is
displayed here
this is actually uh having some
mathematical meaning behind it
so this is just a cosmetic thing here
whatever is present in this markdown
cell
that is just a cosmetic thing cosmetic
means it is just
a like a like a
like a writing okay it is there is no
math mathematical meaning
inherent to it but here what you see
that is that has mathematical meaning
okay uh all right
i shouldn't say mathematical meaning
rather i should say mathematical life
in it uh anyway so we want to solve it
so the the way we can solve it is to
just
use the the linear solved command
which is same dot then solve we also
have a separate solved command
but i think because we are specifically
solving linear simultaneous equations
these jobs and this does the job well
okay
so you note this syntax that i'm using
here
so first of all i am placing within
square brackets
the two equations that i need to solve
okay so if you have any number of
equations you need to put them
sequentially
in this kind of square bracket and then
you also have to mention
uh which are the variables you are
solving for
okay so you can you can write like this
uh x comma y close bracket
uh and shift enter
so you can actually verify that uh the
solution
this 1 corresponds to x and this
2 corresponds to y so if you have x
equal to 1 y equal to 2
it actually solves this equation so
twice
plus 3 to 2 6 that's 8 and
3 into 1 is 3 plus 2 is 5.
now we can have this in a in a slightly
better fashion
in this way okay so we can say we can
assign
the solution variable to the to the
output but
we have to do a little bit of a quirky
python thing here
so we need to put a comma here okay let
us not get into the details of
why we need to put that comma right now
okay slowly as we learn
things we can we can delve deeper into
those nitty-gritty details
uh but now if i press shift enter
well nothing is displayed as you can
expect okay
so if we want to see what is present
inside the solution variable
what we can do is we can display
solution but now
okay let's let's do a shift enter and
see what happens
okay so you see this is uh
one and two okay now suppose we want to
extract
only the first one okay so the x
solution and the y solution separately
so what we can do is we can do something
like this
we can say x solution is equal to
solution
index 0. so unlike matlab
where the indexing starts from 1
in python you have the indexing starting
from zero
okay so that's similar to c the c
program programming language
uh so the second solution will be given
by solution one
okay
so now we can display this x solution
and y solution
all right now this definitely looks good
but uh i mean if you
uh if you're really demanding customer
uh you will perhaps uh have a little bit
of a grievance that it is not really
clear if i just write this display
solution y solution
i mean which i mean is this x or this is
y of course
the way that you set up the variables it
is definitely clear but
uh in a more involved situation
because you note that you will certainly
not use symbolic python to do these
kinds of trivial calculations which you
can do orally
in fact this is only for demonstration
purposes and later when you
do 2d elasticity problems where there
will be number of equations to solve
simultaneously
it will perhaps be better if you can
display the variable names uh beside the
the solution okay so
uh we can do this with a little bit of
more effort and in a very big very nice
visual way so
for that what we'll do is we'll have to
write a few more things
but once we do that we can just keep on
repeating the same thing okay
so so i i uh i mean it's it's worth the
effort
okay so let me demonstrate this so uh
so what i'm going to write next maybe
start looking a little bit completely
alien but i'll just explain okay let me
write down the thing
so from ipython dot display input
map from latex okay so
i'll go into a little bit of explanation
of that in a while let me just
demonstrate
what i what i mean to say so display
uh
let me just quickly write it down and
then i'll tell what i
i'm doing
okay let's do a shift enter so this is
what i wanted to show you
so x equal to 1 and y equal to 2 okay so
this is again
just a visual output this by itself has
no mathematical life of its own
it's just like type setting so what i've
done here is that
uh there is something called this
ipython now
uh if you know a little bit of uh
history behind it or if you read up on
it
you'll see this jupiter notebook is uh
kind of a successor
of of something which was
uh which people came up with earlier
uh which is called ipython okay
and the kind of successor to the jupiter
notebook is something which is being
used widely nowadays called the jupiter
lab
but uh for our preliminary uh kind of
work uh
it we won't need jupiter lab okay uh
now many of the things that we are using
in jupyter notebook directly derived
from i
python okay so this is something so so
this
this uh this special way of displaying
our
our information our solutions and other
things
so uh it is it is derived from that
ipython thing so
that that's what we are uh that's what
we're importing here
uh so this has a number of different
packages within it
uh like sub packages within it so two of
them are math and latex
uh and we are using that uh here okay
so let me not get too much into it but
uh what i am doing here with this r
thing is this is
so this uh this bit present let me just
highlight it this
big present here within the single
quotes that's like the raw string
of a latex command but it also has
this kind of a uh
of a blank entry which we fill it up
with this format command
okay so this
x solution is something which we obtain
as part of our calculations as we have
seen in the previous cell
here and we can use that
to fill it up here okay so if you had
filled it up here
if you had written x solution here that
would have just printed out x
uh so ln okay that is something we don't
want we want to actually extract the
the value present within the x solution
variable
and and put that here uh in a nice latex
format
again the same thing goes for the wise
okay uh
so so i i think this this really helps
us
in in clearly looking at the solution
anyway
so this is what it is uh and we will be
using this a lot
uh as we go along in our 2d elasticity
uh calculations and solutions
all right so uh with this uh i think
i have more or less covered uh
what i wanted to cover in this very very
introductory very basic
uh jupiter notebook discussion please
note that this is
like uh not even scratching the surface
uh
of of the introduction of jupiter
notebook
uh but i think i have more or less
and covered what what we'll be using
quite a bit in the coming classes uh
now there is another
dimension to it altogether okay so
the calculus part which we can discuss
in another
subsequent lecture all right thank you
very much